qui êtes vous que faites vous dans la
vie mon os et fondtech je suis chef et
prêteurs du restant de retard car donc
quand fu est plus qu on est de fous plus
on rit on note iphone si vous allez dans
le vietnam dans le chu de foot vous
allez voir que le monde mange à
l'extérieur sur techno cela fut faste
sans vis à bois la surface fantax la
connaît bien dans ta famille est ce que
c'était très populaire que qui le
faisait chez vous non mais maslakov
c'est le goûteur la recette que tu fais
ici au restaurant ce qui est inspiré de
tonnerre ou ses auteurs oublient de ma
mère et spirit des amis qui m'ont aidé
un petit peu on travaille ensemble
monter la sauce fort parce que chaque
personne créer leur propre sort
et puis la même chose comme avoir une
recette c'est sûr qu'une base mais
chacun a sa spécialité la soupe fra est
appelé aussi soupe tonkinoise à cause de
la région de tan kin au nord du vietnam
nous elle tirait son origine ici on la
mange comme repas au dîner ou souper
mais c'est le matin qu on la sert au
vietnam
comment petit déjeuner avec un petit
café ou salés comme cité ça fait leur
bonheur puis sa part la journée dans le
sud du vietnam
on sert le bouillon avec la viande dans
un bol et on place les garnitures et les
sauces
à côté dans nord du vietnam on ajoute
rillettes qu'un conte amène ton peuple
tu rajoutes proviennent de banquet je
savais comme ça parce qu'ils veulent que
tu coupes sur rosa rompit itou qui ont
mis la temps tandis que dans le sud
on vient avec des herbes à côté à faire
germer les petites sauces
la version qu'on connaît ici c'est plus
la version du sud sud américanisé aussi
ouais le gros bol habituellement cas que
dimanche la soupe tonkinoise au viet-nam
c'est du people
surtout le matin tantôt si je prends ma
main je jouais au goûter au bouillant
ouais la pression je vois le barbouillé
de sortie c'est ça exactement où est
fait comme chez american is even a pas
de secret une bonne soupe ça commence
par un bon bouillon bien qu'on le trouve
à base de poulet ou de poisson
le classique est à base de boeuf qu'est
ce qui fait que le bouillon est bon
c'est la durite qui somme qu'est ce
qu'il ya dedans nous qu'est-ce que je
mets ce plus les autres boeufs tu peux
mettre extérieures zoug trimestre le
risque est que comme une viande aux
familles j'étais apprécié les oignons
grillés visé avec les jambes pliées
surprenant mais important bien grillé
même presque brûlé l'oignon et le
gingembre pour donner un concentré de
saveurs oubliées pendant huit ans plus
tard
qu'est-ce que tu mets dans les épices
les toits d'année si la cannelle
des épices tendrement terrifiés à la
pointe après c'est aussi le sucre de
palme que jamais du peu de sel un peu de
sauce poisson qui est très important la
cuisine dynamique pour faire le bouillon
il existe aussi une poudre et des épices
prête à utiliser qui se vendent dans les
marchés asiatiques
c'est comme quand tu as des enfants qui
tous tués par quelque chose rapidement
c'était pas le temps d'attendre pendant
huit heures si les gens pas la chance de
venir goûter exactement une version
courte exact exact avant de servir le
bol on cuit des nouilles de riz et on
réchauffe la viande avec le bouillon je
connais bien qu'on aime les boulettes de
boeuf après s'être faufilé qui est une
viande qui est enseignante qui face à la
cure aussi après cette langue
le risque est que je suis prend 12 ans
dans ce projet pour l'attendre
exactement et à la façon sud
vietnamienne on se laisse aller avec les
garnitures herbe l'hymne sauce origines
et sauce piquante thérapeutique en tête
à petit la première fois que moi et moi
chine au vietnam fait que je j j'en ai
mangé mais je me rappelle pas je suis
venu ici ma mère n'a fait légitime au
hockey c'est quelque chose qui était
quelques cheveux s'il s'est inspiré de
la soupe de sa mère fang il va aussi de
son inspiration bien à lui merci
beaucoup chef pour déjeuner le matin
déjà des sapins aux appétits solide et
se mélanger les larges et comme
s'exprimant j'ai un petit peu nos
attitudes peuvent ensemble puis avec
desservent le 30 juillet
qu'est ce que tu peux froid directement
ça réchauffe complet devant mes yeux
[Musique]